so the audience reactions of this is
insane people have never seen anything
like it what was your first reaction
when you saw it
luckily I had the opportunity to sneak
into a screening oh yeah and it was the
first time it had ever been seen by any
audience and they weren't they they
didn't know obviously I sat in the back
of the theater and the last room came in
after the lights went down and to see it
and to also you know see it with in the
room with so much energy and to see and
feel the vibrations of that reactions
and the energy of the crowd was truly a
remarkable experience and the movie is
something to see and behold in and of
itself I can say that and I never say
that about my movies I don't normally
watch them but I I I know that from when
I did it was it's incredibly hard to
watch them and feel like it's hard to be
objective you remember being there yeah
you remember filming that thing you
remember how it felt or whatever you've
seen it before and with Aquaman you know
in this movie the nature of this movie
is such that there was a lot there's so
much room for for the digital effects in
the world to be put in after that we
weren't able to see and touch and and
and be part of an and function around
while shooting and it created this
there's a disparity you know and in what
you could an expectation and imagination
and I was blown away when I sat in the
theater and saw this world come to life
that I had only seen or had pieces of
imaginings of you know while shooting
because so much is digital and it was
just truly spectacular I was blown away
I mean I really James wanted created it
has created this incredibly submersible
experience that really takes you away
and it reminds me of what it's like to
be a kid you know and you see a movie in
the theatre like this which is how you
should see it it's just truly right you
need to be you go through all these
worlds that you've never seen her for
it's really it's really takes it
strength it really transports you it
looks like one of the most unique
filmmaking experiences of all time one
of the cool things that you guys
share screen time with Legends you got
to share screen time with Nicole Kidman
yeah Nicole Kidman's amazing what she's
such a force she's talented next-level
talented obviously and she's also a
beautiful human and Willem Dafoe he
could not be and he's also a beautiful
human I mean it's just really a unicorn
some people I really I really lucked out
I really lucked out with this cast so
what do you do after a full day of like
a really suspended kung fu green screen
combat wearing a full-on like superhero
skintight suit like how do you relax I
had when I filmed this I have a I mean
when I filmed this movie in Australia we
had a little wine club yeah and so me
and some of the crew who are into wine
we just all we'd open up a bottle and
we'd all share a bottle and I was
getting you know and we call it
de-rigged and you know that process
alone of getting out of the costume
taking off hair and makeup and and and
Dee wigging and all of the things that
go into making it like people don't
realize you know by the time we're we're
getting to rehearsal I've already been
there for three and a half four hours
and to get out of the costume alone it
was like you know 30 minutes I mean
that's like when it was streamlined I
mean that was at the end like this
deserves a drink
yes wine like
you